musicien et designer graphique Quentin
aura est l'un des plus jeunes artistes
Orléanais a participé à orléanoïde ses
installations mettent en relation le son
et
l'image Jacques do est une performance
où les corps se transforment en
instrument
électronique même démarche pour
pentatonique avec lesbattement du cœur
d'une performeuse la semaine dernière
équipée de capteurs sonores aux
chevilles et aux avant-bras elle dansait
dans la
collégiale le dispositif rejoue lui-même
la performance mais sans le performeur
voilà c'est une sorte d'absence comme ça
qui reste présence présence absence et
qui c'est ce jeu entre la présence et
l'absence qui du coup euh va faire va
créer une tension il va révéler un petit
peu le corps comme si s étaient incarnés
en quelque sorte dans le son et dans la
lumière dans ombre à air il n'y a pas de
magie l'artiste s'intéresse à la
distance entre le réel et le
virtuel on a on a créé un dispositif
comme ça qui un petit peu illusioniste
en fait euh pour rendre compte un peu de
quelque chose qui qui paraît tellement
évident dans sa forme et à la fois il y
a quelque chose qui cloche j'aime bien
ce ce un peu transgresser la
perception Quentin s'appuie sur les
caractéristiques du lieu existant ici un
ancien atelier de forgeron pour brouer
les pistes entre espace visible et
invisible il s'agit d'une d'une plaque
de tôle avec des ressorts qui sont qui
sont
amplifiés
et Don le le son qui émane de cette
sculpture et amplifier va ressurgir à
l'extérieur de l'installation donc à
l'extéeur de la vitrine à travers le
superil qui donne directement sur la rue
et c'est un moyen comme ça de la
sculpture qui est derrière la vitrine
s'invite un petit peu dans l'espace
public demain soir à 11 Pierrette du
poer racontera la vie de Jean j à sa
manière
VI un peu de douceur demain soir
avecoporose au nouvel atrium de
Saint la Loir band sable paysag
impressionnistes sont inspirés Édouard
de baponzan l'artiste a aussi tenté de
réhabiliter
drefus au total ce sont 80 tableaux à
découvrir au musée des beauxards de
tour Stevens jouera jeudi soir au
bouillon l'occasion d'écouter les titres
de son prochain album qui sortira en
mars
prochain
la semaine prochaine l'agenda rendra
visite à un plasticien tour Eno etry